it's never been easier for Claudette
Irae ray to catch the bus in Rwanda as
capital cashless transactions are made
using a prepaid bus ticket from err
clerk the technology behind it was
developed at K lab an open IT workspace
in Kigali it's a hub for a Wanda's
fledgling tech industry more and more
people in the capital are getting
onboard to this digital revolution this
is one really tangible example
about success stories of Caleb why
because Patrick and his friends they
simply came up with a simple idea but
then is so efficient
Caleb's name is a mix of knowledge and
IT lab this is where ideas are turned
into reality
caleb offers plenty of space for young
developers to test out their new
programs claudette array Rey would like
to see more digital products made for
everyday applications the IT industry
points to a potential way out of poverty
which is bound up with knowledge and
training people have I wouldn't say that
it's you know where we would want them
to be we're getting there
Rwanda is a landlocked country which
makes economic development challenging
it has very few natural resources still
the economy is growing steadily at an
annual pace of 8% here digitalization is
an important resource ICT has the
ability of you know being exported and
imported at a zero rate no it's a zero
kg that's why they keep saying at a zero
rate so there's no cost conferences and
digital industry meetings are one way
rwanda has successfully showcased its IT
competencies such events bring investors
developers and distributors together an
ideal platform for the Caleb developers
I would want to see more I would want to
see many more applications being
produced and they're irrelevant to our
challenges I would want to see them more
engaged I would want to see them more
exposed I want to see them you know
growing and selling their small ventures
that chimes with president Paul Kagame
is vision he's promoting digital
development in Rwanda it's now down to
people like Claudette arrey arrey and
other young developers to make this
dream come true